this is the design of Amsterdam's new
erotic Center
commissioned by the city government in
2020 it's a concept for a 5 000 square
meter high-rise with hotel rooms offices
bars entertainment facilities a store
and a restaurant
when it's finished it will be one of
Europe's largest and most advanced
brothels
and as interesting as its design are the
locations that it's being considered for
locations on the outskirts of the city
so why did Amsterdam's government
commission the design of this new
building
Wyatt locations far from its historic
redlit Center
and why are people so angry
back in 2009 a labor politician waited
the city was voting on a plan he had
spearheaded a plan called project 1012
named after the zip code of the city's
most notorious red light district it was
designed to clean it up low quality
buildings such as window brothels and
coffee shops had to go but instead of
making new regulations the lawmaker was
praised for a unique approach
his solution was spatial by a buildings
associated with crime and push crime
away the city government was convinced
and his plan would pass little did they
all know it would soon collapse
over the course of more than a decade it
would lead to the closure of more than a
hundred individual window brothels along
with tens of individual coffee shops
however when attempts were made to
measure the impact of project 1012 not
much could be found
it had a marginal impact on crime and
today the center's image as an adult
theme park with Shady edges still remain
strong but if there's one thing his plan
did do was that it created a rift among
hundreds of sex workers in the city
government of Amsterdam one that
persists even as the newest mayor picks
up the mantle again and tries to change
the center even more
in 2020 the city government banned
organized tours of the red light
district in May of 2023 bands on
cannabis within the district entirely
there's also been mandated bar closures
bans on the sale and display of alcohol
and even ad campaigns targeted towards
young to middle-aged British men
she in the executive body have even
floated the idea of banning
International tourists from buying
marijuana in the city entirely
she's also brought up the idea of
introducing entrance gates to the red
light district this would create the
first physically regulated neighborhood
in a major European city not even Venice
does that
but our most controversial suggestions
started soon after her nomination in
2019 when she brought attention towards
changing the rooms in the red light
district again
[Music]
Amsterdam there are actually three
separate red light districts the most
well known is in the center called
davala which has 249 rooms but the other
two and much less well-known are the
single khobit and the rostolkata which
if 63 and 40 rooms respectively in 2019
femca halsima the newest mayor of
Amsterdam presented four scenarios for
the future of the Vala
three of those scenarios targeted each
of these districts in order to reduce
over tourism
her first scenario was to change window
prostitution permanently
Amsterdam closes all the curtains in the
vola and single while the rooms stay
open
if a lot of the attraction to the red
light district is simply to be able to
walk around and look take away what
people look at and you not only reduce
potential tourists but push the tourists
that do come to other parts of the city
with increased digitization sex workers
can increasingly rely on getting clients
via their phones rather than off the
streets
the assumption is that this would just
speed up an inevitable transformation
from physical Windows to digital ones
in her second scenario Amsterdam would
see the most radical change all the
rooms in the vola and single are removed
and shifted to other parts of the city
the number of rooms does not change like
it did in Project 1012 but their
locations do
however because closing all the rooms in
Nevada is highly unrealistic the city
government is going forward with
hulsimus third and most realistic
scenario
instead of all a chunk of the rooms in
the vola and single are moved
although it's more realistic the city
government has not made it clear how
large that chunk will actually be
but different from Project 1012 alsama
has made the commitment that when rooms
get removed they have to come someplace
new
at the start the government considered
two building types a single unit
high-rise and the second a cluster of
different multi-function buildings
they also commissioned Research into
building on a floating Pavilion
the design is meant to anticipate for
about a hundred individual rooms for sex
workers and also other entertainment
facilities
on the one hand the city wants to model
Pasha when it comes to size Posh is the
world's largest brothel however it's not
a particularly welcoming or friendly
looking building so on the other hand
they also want to model the more modern
less sketchy design of antwerp's largest
brothel Villa Tinto
but these brothels aside there's a few
things that make Amsterdam's new erotic
Center completely different
the mayor of Amsterdam knows that a
brothel is controversial this is why she
hopes Amsterdam can make one with class
and distinction
by mixing hotel rooms with painting
courses art exhibitions in a debate
Center the hope is that they can avoid
designing an isolated sex Palace
for an actual physical model they
commissioned Moog a Dutch architecture
Studio to come up with a design
The Architects giannisito and Jurgen
tenhuva designed a concept that attempts
to convert the linear streets of the red
light district into a circular form
inspired by Frank Lloyd Wright's
Guggenheim Sito when an architecture
prize for making a design that
repurposed two sugar silos into a
cultural center with internal circular
walkways
the other architect was nominated for
the same prize in 2018 for his design of
a collection of buildings modeled after
a monastery
it was a network of buildings
superimposed in Notre Dame that attempts
to give an option for pedestrians to
leave the busyness of the city
together both Architects produce an
interesting combination you get a
building that kind of looks like a
parking garage with A continuous walkway
that allows you to walk in the building
as you would in the vola but circularly
as opposed to linearly
also instead of a floor of the same
individual homogeneous hotel rooms it
also attempts to recreate the network of
the buildings on the street on each
individual floor as well
to choose a location for the building
the city government considered eight
regions and as of today they've narrowed
it down to two main locations and ASM in
north and around the guy in zoud
in North Amsterdam would have to deviate
someone from the original Moog design
and construct a floating brothel
it's likely that it'll be a Bonton of
around 100 by 20 meters with two
thousand square meters of space for five
total floors
one basement One Roof Terrace and with
the remainder holding the rooms and
other facilities
the government also considered
repurposing a cruise ship since it would
already be readily equipped with rooms
bars theaters and attractions like
casinos however a cruise ship has a
large number of constraints making it an
unlikely option
and asm's preferred location comes from
the fact that it's a diverse culturally
rich neighborhood
there's plenty of room for additional
buildings such as for any needed
security or additional parking but it
also hosts one of the largest flea
markets in Europe has multiple popular
restaurants and cultural attractions and
it also has a high density of mixed
residential use areas
nonetheless ndsm has a weakness its most
immediate connection is via Ferry not
only is that slower than other forms of
public transport but a ferry can only
withstand so many more people
Amsterdam has considered Building
Bridges to North but it's unclear how
long that would take or if they'll ever
be built at all
so ndsm's main fault is its reachability
but ndsm's biggest benefit is that it's
considerably hipper than the other
section of the city that's under
consideration
is the poshest and most entitled area of
Amsterdam and offers two plots the
grunozone a 2 000 square meter
triangular piece of land and then a
second likely the preferred option a 21
500 square meter plot of land owned by
the city government directly
unlike the singular Ferry Connection in
Nord zet has access to two Metro
connections
one that goes from north to south giving
potential clients from the center and
media access and it also has a Metro
going from east to west granting direct
access to Amsterdam's business district
what it loses in being a hip and chill
place to be it gains inaccessibility it
also has ample parking space
however what both North and South still
have in common is that there are nimbies
homeowners have voiced concerns about
noise criminality and impact on children
in the area
some sex workers have also voiced
concerns about their own safety
according to the city government the
building will likely be a safer option
than the status quo instead of sparse
separated buildings in an overcrowded
neighborhood a single building would
have a centralized security system with
a clear oversight over who enters and
who leaves
the erotic Center does what project 1012
couldn't it gets rid of rooms in the
center but without pushing sex workers
into an unregulated underground
also unlike the vola which makes his
tourists with potential clients the new
building is meant to attract primarily
the clients
some sex workers have complained that
over tourism has reduced their incomes
because large crowds make actual
potential clients too self-conscious to
consume according to the city government
a well-connected but more isolated
building reduce the attraction of the
red light district for tourists attract
more clients than in the center
increasing sex workers incomes but it
would also be quieter tourists are loud
but clients are the type of people who
want to be private and have as little
attention drawn to them as possible
however this is also where some more
difficult problems emerge
davola with all of its issues still has
a unique Advantage there's a lot of eyes
on the street in the same way that it
may make some clients too self-conscious
to consume it may do the same for more
serious criminals and this is where you
get the nimbies
homeowners would like a building that's
as invisible as possible this is why the
mayor has also promised a closed
isolated building that brings very
little attention
however the more isolated and quiet the
area the more concerns about sex workers
safety also the city already has
problems with the number of police and
security since the vola isn't entirely
removed by building a neurotic Center
you end up producing a fourth red light
district which potentially spreads an
already thin police force even thinner
so the mayor has had problems she's
faced considerable backlash at town
halls and she's had to postpone making
decisions on the erotic Center
however since 2021 hulsma has had a
majority in the government people can
postpone and argue all they want but all
three parties hunlings Des
have agreed beat an isolated building
cruise ship floating Pavilion North or
in South some rooms in the vola must be
removed and instead they must come
somewhere new however a new erotic
Center may not even be Amsterdam's most
controversial plan the city government
has also proposed replacing its historic
famous public urinals with an advanced
ai-powered urinal that comes out of the
ground
the story is fascinating and I've made
an entirely different video on it that
you can watch right now on nebula
create your own streaming service where
I'm posting the genius design of Dutch
public urinals early as well as my
future videos
once you're there you can also check out
my video on Corby Shay's plan for
Gigantic Highway skyscraper and you can
watch other exclusive videos made by
channels like Neo mustard city beautiful
and countless others nebula is great and
I really cannot stress that enough
it not only gives me the freedom to
spend excessive amounts of time in a
basement making videos for strangers on
the internet but it also provides great
videos that you can watch nowhere else
and also classes so that you too can
also learn how to make videos in your
basement like I do untouched public
urinals
if you sign up using the link below you
can support me directly and get both
nebula and nebula classes for 40 off
annual plan which is as little as 2.50 a
month